>> Well Haiti is now facing an emergency.
It was one of the worst disaster that mankind
faced in the last
centuries.
So this is the most immediate thing.
But as you deal with this question which implies
food, implies medical,
implies shelter as you deal with these -- water
-- as you deal with
these more immediate questions you must also
think in the medium and
the long term.
A lot progress has been made before the earthquake
in the political
front, in the security front, in the -- even
in the economic front
because there was more interest of business
people.
We have to now harness all these interests
and make it come again and
you see because there is no way that you can
separate completely the
emergency from the long term.
So I -- the sooner the business people come
there also, and start to
make their plans as people said here in the
tourism industry, garment,
Brazilian industries are very interested -- ethanol
is very [INAUDIBLE]
in Brazil can help but in order help Haiti
there we have the technology
and we have even the disposition, but you
have to have the market.
So you have to have facilities in the U.S.,
Canada, or European markets
so they we can do that as well.
That's just as an example.